Bộ nơi vụ thái lan thông báo chính quyền 2 tình bến dổi U-Bong và Chá Thá Nịt và Sisa Két đã tổ chức họ cần.
Để sây dựa con an sơ tảng người dân trong trường tăng thảng bến dổi và công buổi chia theo thang.
Đông thái này, giễn ra sau cuộc sông độ phụ trang dựa quân đội hai nước, phùm hai người tạm thằng năm.
Tại khu vực ra ra anh tình U-Bong và Chá Thá Nị Thái Lan và tình Brier VH của Cám buổi chia.
Khiến một bình sĩ có buổi chia thêm bà theo chia đạo từ phó khu tưởng thái lan.
Chuyến quyền đều phương được yêu cầu tăng cường có biển pháp đàn bảo an ninh.
Đông thời đánh giá khi í các người cơ bảo trình bị sản sản kế hoài xưa tán.
Bộ chỉ nơi cư chú tăng thời nếu cần thiết.
Các phương an đã được thảo lộ chi tết, người càng két phản nếu kìp thời để đàn bảo an toàn trường này dân.
Trong ai một đủ thằng sau, chính phủ thái lan cũng ra thông cao báo chi thằng định lập trường,
kênh quyết bảo vệ chủ quyền lạnh thổ.
Nhưng mạnh mọi hành động của nước này đến nay điều phủ hồn lật pháp của thế.
Mọi người có thể đánh phủ hồn lật pháp,
hồn lật pháp của thế.
Mọi người có thể đọc có thể, kìa tình thành lâu thang.
Chuyến phủ thái lan kêu gọi người dân tiên tương và đội lức của nhà nước.
Trong việc truyến chí của định phủ hồn lật pháp,
mọi người có thể làm gì những chuyện với cây phù chia và càng két tiếp tục thuốc để các bạn pháp pháp pháp bình.
Tắt sông phương để kìm xóa tình thịnh và tránh hiểu lần rồi bên.